you can stay seated for the moment Mrs
sakulas
on the 27th of August 2019
you drove out of the military base at
Raf croughton
and turned left onto the b4031
towards croughton Village
it was about 8 20 in the evening there
was good visibility
two of your own children were in the
back of your car
when you turned you immediately went
onto the wrong side of the road
where you traveled for about
350 meters
just less than 30 seconds later your car
hit the motorcycle being ridden by Harry
Dunn who was just 19 years old
he had spent the 27th of August 2019
with his best friend
he was happy he loved motorbikes
there is no suggestion that he was
driving anything other than entirely
properly
he was on the right side of the road
driving perfectly normally
excessive speed was not involved
on either side
at the point of the Collision there was
a slight Bend and rise in the road
the impact with the front of your car
through him onto the front of your car
and then over the top of it until he
landed in the road
his bike caught fire and was pushed
backwards
another driver arrived soon afterwards
and called the Emergency Services
you got out realized what had happened
and were very distressed
you spoke to Mr Dunn who was conscious
and speaking you got your children out
of the car and called your husband and
the RAF base
you confirmed to the police
that what happened was your fault and
you had been on the wrong side of the
road
a breath test was administered and was
negative
you said you had made a mistake
Mr Dunn suffered multiple severe
injuries
he was very Gravely ill when he was
taken to hospital and he died soon
afterwards
you were not arrested at the time you
did not remain in the United Kingdom you
left on the 15th of September 2019
you submitted to a voluntary interview
with the police in Washington D.C on the
28th of October
as you had at the roadside you admitted
you were responsible
a request for your extradition was
submitted in 2020
it was denied
immunity from Criminal prosecution was
claimed for you by the government of the
United States of America and accepted by
the British government
as the high court of justice in London
found in its judgment on the challenge
of Mr Dunn's parents to that decision
in in the crown on the application of
Charlotte Charles and Tim Dunn against
the Secretary of State for the foreign
and Commonwealth Affairs and the chief
Constable of northamptonshire police
2020
ewhc 3185 admin you did indeed enjoy
that immunity at the time of the
accident which killed their son
there is no doubt that the calm and
dignified Persistence of these parents
and the family of that young man
has led through three years of
heartbreak and effort to your appearance
before the court and the opportunity for
you to acknowledge acknowledge your
guilt of a crime
eventually you are charged with death by
dangerous driving by written requisition
pursuant to section 3 of the crime
International cooperation Act 2003.
changes in the law wrought by part 8 of
the criminal justice act 2003
by the police crime sentencing and court
site 2022 guaranteed powers or rather
granted powers to the criminal courts to
permit a person to take part in criminal
proceedings through a live link
the chief magistrate granted a live link
order and you appeared before
Westminster magistrates court on the
29th of September 2022
your case was sent to the central
Criminal Court
by participating in video link
proceedings at Westminster magistrates
you surrendered to the court
when your case was sent for trial to
this court you were given unconditional
bail
surrender to this court was accomplished
when you were identified as being
present Again by video link on the 20th
of October 2022
you were arraigned and you pleaded
guilty to a lesser offense that of
causing death by careless or
inconsiderate driving contrary to
section 2B of the Road Traffic Act 1988.
the court granted a live link for your
arraignment because in my judgment it
was in the public interest for you to be
able to enter your plea
and it would not defeat the interests of
Justice if that was accomplished by you
participating through a live link
at no point in these proceedings had it
been suggested that you were not free
and able to travel to this jurisdiction
in person
once you had pleaded guilty and were
therefore a convicted offender there
could be little reason in a case where a
young man had met his death for you not
to be required to attend at court for
sentence
your bail was not withdrawn and you were
released from the court but directed to
attend in person for this sentencing
hearing
I directed you to attend and observed
that attendance in person would be
strong evidence of remorse
for the purpose of section 6-1 of the
bay light 1976 you had a duty to
surrender to the court
failure of a defendant in a criminal
trial to attend in person when directed
to do so without reasonable cause is an
offense contrary to the bailout
it has the potential to affect the
Court's ability to administer Justice by
damaging the confidence of victims
Witnesses and the public more generally
in the effectiveness of the court system
judges have to consider taking
appropriate action if there is no
sufficient justification for a failure
to attend
the usual action is to issue a bench
warrant not backed for bail which will
result in the arrest of the defendant
when they are located
your sentence is due to take place on
the 1st of December a week before that
date on the 24th of November the court
received a renewal of the application
for you to appear by live link
this included references to harassment
and threats you and your family had
received mainly by social media and many
emanating from the United States of
America
and an assessment that this gave rise to
a risk to your personal safety if you
travel to the United Kingdom
it did not include any reference to a
barrier imposed by the government
authorities to your traveling to London
to face sentence in person
as a consequence of what the court
received I asked the prosecution to
provide a response to the material
submitted
very swiftly by the 28th of November the
northamptonshire police
compiled an operation which set out in
detail for Plans by means of which your
safety could be protected if you were to
return to the jurisdiction to be
sentenced
accordingly I maintained my order that
the hearing be in person
however a request was made on your
behalf for a delay of a week to obtain
further Evidence
this was allowed
on Friday the 2nd of December a
statement was served from Amy Jeffries
your attorney who accompanies you today
and I granted the application on Monday
the 5th of December
the reasons were that for the first time
in these criminal proceedings a barrier
to your attendance emanating from the
American government was relied on in
support of the application
in her statement Miss Jeffrey says quote
the U.S government does not in any way
support mississ
appearing in person at this hearing in
fact Mrs sakulis's U.S government
employer has advised her not to return
to the United Kingdom in person for this
hearing because her return could place
significant U.S interests at risk this
advice was communicated to her by her
employer on the 30th of November and she
is not at Liberty to disclose the
communication itself or any further
information to the court
by section 51 subsection 3 of the
criminal justice act 2003 as amended by
section 200 of the pcsca 2022 a
sentencing hearing Falls within the list
of eligible criminal proceedings for
which the court has the power to make a
direction pursuant to section 51
subsection 1.
and that power may be exercised in
respect of a person who is outside the
jurisdiction of England and Wales
but the power is subject to section 51
subsection 4A which requires that the
court is satisfied amongst other things
that it is in the interests of Justice
to make the direction
the interests of Justice in a criminal
case are frequently different to the
interests of the defendant
respect for the law must be genuine and
effective substantial and real
the Lord chief justice has provided the
courts with guidance which must be
considered alongside all the
circumstances of the case
and particular factors which are set out
in section 51 subsection 6 of the cja
one of those factors is the need for the
defendant to attend in person
paragraph 9 of the guidance issued by
the Lord chief justice invites attention
to such factors as the potential penalty
to be imposed and in paragraph 18
whether a live link would risk damaging
international relations so as to be
contrary to the interests of Justice
when sentences to be imposed for an
offense that involves the fatality there
must be a strong public interest in the
offender being before the court in
person
in other words a need for the defendant
to attend in person
as will become apparent I concluded
provisionally and subject to hearing the
submissions in mitigation today that the
barrier presented by your adherence to
the advice given to you by your
government employer was relevant to my
decision on the use of a live link and
it would not interfere with the due
administration of justice given the
sentence I was likely to impose
the Alternatives would have been to
withdraw your bail if you had not
attended today the result would have
been a warrant for your arrest which
would have been extant until executed or
withdrawn
the issuing of a warrant for your arrest
would have been close to an empty
gesture and it would stall progress in
this case
another option open to the court would
have been to conduct a sentence in your
absence as you are represented by
Council and the court has material upon
which to proceed
it would have been perverse to review to
refuse this video link in these
circumstances and on the 5th of December
I granted the application which remained
a joint one by the defense and the
prosecution
in an eloquent impact statement
Charlotte Charles Harry Dunn's mother
has expressed her sorrow at not being
able to comfort her son as he lay on the
side of the road or in hospital
she is full of regrets
her other son Harry's not twin Niall
feels emptiness
the Deep suffering of the entire family
at the unusual course of events I have
outlined has generated the persistence
that she and her and Harry's father have
shown
she wants Justice for her son
as she promised him
although they've been left with a gaping
hole the family is determined to provide
a legacy for him in projects to help
others
who are you and sakulas
you are a citizen of the United States
of America
you are 45 years old and happily married
with three children of your own age 7 9
and 14 years
you accompanied your husband on his
posting to RAF croughton having arrived
a few weeks before the accident
you had been socializing on the base on
the 27th of August with your husband and
children
he left the base shortly before you and
according to the material before me you
decided to drive home the way he did
even though you are less familiar with
it than another route that you knew
you have expressed your condolences to
Mr Dunn's family through a statement
read by Council on your behalf at this
hearing
causing death by careless or
inconsiderate driving contrary to
section 2B of the Road Traffic Act 1988
can be committed in various ways
sometimes a moment's inattention can
lead to tragic results
this is not such a case
you drove along the wrong side of the
road for much more than a moment
and you did not realize what you were
doing even when you were coming to A
bend in the road when all drivers on a
narrow carriageway would naturally check
that they were driving safely
it seems to me that your conduct albeit
careless rather than deliberate Falls at
The Other Extreme
taking everything into account your
behavior on this occasion was not far
short of deliberately dangerous driving
which results in a death
I bear in mind that this was a short
period of driving and you were not
familiar with English roads
the sentencing Council guideline places
the starting point for sentence for your
offense at 15 months custody
the range it provides is nine months to
three years custody
the death of Harry Dunn is of course the
highest degree of harm
but that is inherent in the charge and
the starting point of 15 months
there are none of the aggravating
features that may appear in some such
cases for example you are not driving
uninsured
there is mitigation in your case
in particular
you are not compelled to submit yourself
to this charge
and these proceedings but have chosen to
do so
you had only limited experience of
driving in this country
you offered assistance to Mr Dunn at the
scene and you have never personally
denied responsibility for his death
other features such as the short time
you drove before the Collision also
alleviate the gravity to a degree
you are to be treated as of good
character apart from two minor driving
matters in 1997 and 2006 both of which
resulted in fines
anyone who has caused death by driving
would be expected to feel remorseful
but remorse is important for sentencing
purposes and I accept that you felt and
feel genuine remorse
these features require a reduction in
the starting point and I allow three
months
you indicated a guilty plea to this
offense in the magistrates court and you
entered your guilty plea at the first
opportunity in the Crown Court the law
requires a one-third discount to
recognize this
the shortest term of imprisonment
commensurate with the seriousness of the
offense is therefore eight months
imprisonment
it follows that the offense is so
serious that neither a fine alone nor a
community sentence can be justified for
it
imprisonment must always be the last
resort
your offense passes the custody
threshold as I have indicated but before
deciding that no alternative is
appropriate I have considered whether
that can be avoided
I ordered a pre-sentence report at the
last hearing you will have seen that
report the author has provided me with a
great deal of useful information about
you and she has consulted senior
officers and officials at his Majesty's
prison and probation service
however the author concludes with no
recommendation to the court and state
that her inquiries do not reveal any
practical way in which a form of
community sentence or any other
non-custodial disposal imposed by this
court could be managed in the United
States of America
it is obvious that no enforcement can be
carried out
and no breach of an order could be
prosecuted effectively while you
remained abroad
equally no restorative justice process
can take place except in person
I'm grateful to the probation service
for the inquiries they've made
Counsel on your behalf has submitted
that sentence should be deferred and
that you would arrange to do some form
of voluntary work in recompense
I do not consider that there is any
purpose in deferring sentence as the
presenters report makes clear you are
not someone who needs Rehabilitation you
need to be sentenced and then both you
and the family of Harry Dunn can move on
if I were to impose an immediate
custodial sentence then you would be
unlawfully at large thereafter and I
would order you to return to the United
Kingdom to serve it the sentence will be
put into effect if and when you enter
the jurisdiction and surrendered to a
police station
before doing so I have considered
whether it is possible to suspend the
sentence
you have the strong personal mitigation
I have already summarized
you are also a mother of young children
who would suffer disproportionate harm
from your immediate imprisonment and I
am satisfied that appropriate punishment
can be achieved without immediate
custody
please stand up Mrs sakulas
you are disqualified from driving for 12
months
for the offense of causing the death of
Harry Dunn by your careless driving the
sentence is eight months imprisonment
suspended for 12 months
there will be no additional requirements
the sentence means that if in the next
12 months you commit any offense
whether or not it is of the same type
for which I'm sentencing you today you
would find yourself before the court
again
and it is likely that the sentence will
be brought into operation either in full
or in part
thank you very much you may sit down